my guest tonight won a golden globe and
emmy award for her work on the closer
and her new series call your mother airs
wednesdays
at 9 30 p.m on abc please welcome the
lovely the talented i'm thrilled she's
with us she's one of my favorites kyra
sedgwick kira i love seeing you we're
all separated during kovid and then
today i'm driving to work
and i'm like i get my kira time so thank
you
oh my gosh that's so nice yeah it's been
such a long time that i'm so happy to
see you
even under these circumstances yeah i
know this is nice where are you right
now that's a beautiful
it looks like i'm talking to you and
you're in an art museum
i know it's crazy i'm really lucky girl
i live in
in uh i have a place in los angeles
beautiful okay yeah
this is this is my place in los angeles
and yeah i mean i get to see the green i
mean jesus
it's nice it's really nice and and you i
mean all of us
we're all going through the same thing
we're at home or
i get my big thing every day is i get to
come to this abandoned theater
and and and do the show but other than
that i'm at home
and feeling kind of trapped i understand
you got out
you actually went out for an evening of
fun how do you do that right now i did
well i got invited to go to this comedy
show
at magic castle and so i went to magic
castle
and it's out it's outdoors right
outdoors but you're in your car
six feet apart and you tune into a radio
station
and i thought this is horrible this is
going to be terrible but then people
came out and they were so funny and they
were so amazing and sherry sheppard was
there and also one of your writers
oh rory lori kilmartin yeah lori
kilmartin
who killed it yes who was absolutely
fantastic
and you know among all the other things
that are incredibly weird about it you
know these poor
first of all it can't have been easy for
these guys i mean it's gotta be so weird
you're like literally looking out on a
sea of cars you can't really hear people
right but give you these plastic
clackers that are just like this
you know horrible like plastic nightmare
that like you're going to throw out
right after you use it
right but you know and it makes a
clapping sound so that the clapping
sound in fact
you're funny today you're funny tonight
i mean because it's night
thank you yeah sure the sun coming in
exactly
that sounds weird no it's good believe
me i can imagine that if i were one of
the comedians up there
this is what i would want to hear it's
awful but you know what
it's better than nothing and of course
i'm so
codependent i'm like my arms like
killing me by the end of it but you know
that's hard to do yeah i would think uh
you know i've been talking to you for a
long time over the years
and i've always loved it when you come
on the program and i realized
that the question my producers and i
think
everybody always wants to ask you is the
same question over and over again and
you must be getting sick of it
which is you've been married you and
kevin bacon have been married for you
know
so many years how do you keep your
marriage happy
what's the secret and i think do you do
you just
ban that question now from interviews no
i don't
because um you know i have a funny
answer
and the and the answer as does kev kev's
is
you keep the fights clean and the sex
dirty
oh people like that one right and mine
is
the secret to a happy marriage is not to
take marital advice
from um celebrities yes that's mine is
to not
not not ask me that question because i
don't have the yet but the true answer
is
and i'm just going to tell you right now
the secret to a happy marriage
is not hanging out together 24 7 365
days a year
yeah i mean like you know
absence make the heart makes the heart
grow fonder and like
you know when you're out in the world
and bringing things back into a marriage
that is a good thing
as long as it's not a third person
unless you're into that stuff
which i am
we'll talk about that later i don't know
if you guys have this but like
as we've been married like our bed has
gotten bigger
you know like like we started out with a
queen for like 20 years we've been
married 32 years and like
21 years in the marriage kev's like i
think we need a better bet
bigger bed and i'm like what a bigger
bed
you know this just at the beginning of
the end i mean i was like really freaked
out by it but then we got a bigger bed
and i was like oh yeah bigger bed
that's good you know what you should try
this is something my wife wanted to try
about two years ago we got bunk beds
so i'm on the top she's on the bottom
there's no physical contact
she doesn't want me touching her um so
it's the top
bed in the bunk bed and then the utility
closet during the day
and we have a very that's how you keep a
marriage going that's the secret
yeah i don't know why bunk beds are just
for kids it's ridiculous
it's a way to keep it going you know
what's amazing is this is very different
for us i know that you had
you guys had kids early and this is
something that
your new show is about call your mother
because you i'm not at the empty nester
stage yet how old are your kids my kids
are
my daughter is 17. and uh
my son is uh 15. so
we're getting there but i still can't
even imagine it
yeah but i know that you had kids early
and so
you've got you you're used to this idea
of it's things are quiet
things are quiet things are different
definitely and
it doesn't suck i mean i really you
should tell your kids that tell your
kids
you know what i love the part when you
went away no
no it sounds it's really is a horrifying
moment when you're like you're really
leaving weight you're really leaving
like i birthed you
and i raised you and now that i've done
my job well you want to leave me
yeah you know but the truth is like you
really do want them to fly away and it's
great
i mean you know it's like you look i had
kids
so young i didn't know anyone who had
kids i i
i don't no one taught me how to do a lot
of the things that like
i grew up in the 70s you know where like
mothers didn't wake up in the morning
and like make their kids breakfast like
i don't know how i got
up i don't know how i got dressed i
don't know how i got to school i mean i
know i did
like but you know i i just your mother
your mother didn't you felt like your
mother didn't teach you the necessary
things you needed to know
here's the thing i can't go into detail
about this because she's definitely
gonna be watching tonight i can just
tell you that right now
suffice to say it's like little things
like
when to go to the dentist and like when
to wash your hands
you know after you use the loo and stuff
like that like if he didn't tell you you
have to wash your hands you have to use
the bathroom
like i said we're not going to go into
detail about this i think he just did
he just did just went into detail but
the thing is
is that when i was 23 and i had this
baby
i was like no one tells you how to do
anything i was 23
kev was 30. we didn't know anything and
also we sort of knew we knew every
thought we knew everything so like
we literally we brought this baby home i
didn't know how to change a diaper
yeah i'm not i'm not exaggerating but we
went through that too
no one tells you any of this stuff oh
and their legs are like this
in the beginning they're completely
folded into each other don't you
remember that or did you not do the did
you not
i when my ever each time my wife
uh gave birth i left for a period of
uh i think a year each time and stayed
at a hotel
and then i came back when i was told the
coast was clear
that was my way of doing it and i think
it was very it's not true
i just trust me i thought about it i
thought about maybe i could just go to a
hotel for a year
and then come back when when my child is
wearing like a little sailor suit he's
like hello father
nice to see you come in i brought you
your slippers
i didn't even know how to like i didn't
need no i
there was a time when my son my first
kid
he started to you know get up out of the
crib
you know at like a very young age like
maybe a year
into it which is something that parents
experience i've since found out but like
i didn't know that this was sort of it
didn't mean that you were supposed to
put them in a big boy bed
which is what i thought i was like oh
well he we were like oh well he's won
and it's time to be in a big boy bed and
we put him in a big boy bed like a real
bed
and we would go downstairs and we'd be
watching tv and we'd hear this giant
phone upstairs and we go
up the stairs and travis had fallen
out of the bed sure and we were like oh
well come on put him back in the bed
you know i didn't even think twice about
i was like oh this is what happens right
like people the kids fall out of bed
so it wasn't until my stepmother came
over one day
and said i said look travis in a big boy
bed she goes you don't have bumpers
on the bed which is like what you do
between
the the crib and the big boy bed you put
in these i was like
oh yeah why it keeps falling out you
know what else works is
duct tape duct tape holds the baby
right there you know i'm curious about
something you're doing this show now
call your mother
and uh one of the things that's so great
about doing
a multi-camera show sitcom is you have
an audience there
and they give you that rush of energy
and you walk in and they're thrilled to
see you
and that's what even when you're
watching those shows
the energy of the audience is what helps
so much and i know that you guys are
making this show
and a very funny comedy but you have to
rely on your own instincts you can't
have an audience
have to ride on your own instincts but
you also have to rely
on like well first of all yes you
definitely have to rely on your own
instincts which may or may not be good
but but
also you have to like rely on your own
ego to like get you through the day
right
i mean are you experiencing this it's
like oh yeah
i have such a big ego and you're right
it's your ego that gets you through
i hear huge laughs in my mind uh
now they probably wouldn't exist in real
life
if there was an audience here but as
long as
my delusion is what's keeping me going
that's really what's keeping me going
yeah give me some of that delusion i've
got
i've got plenty left over
[Laughter]
because i spend a lot of times going
like you suck
well you i don't think you have to worry
about that
uh congratulations on the show call your
mother airs wednesdays at 9
30 on abc and doesn't it feel good to be
making something though i know there's
no audience but
you're you're you're there you're making
something you're making something
funny with people that you like and
that's the blessing
to me it is such a blessing we're really
lucky to be able to do it and to be able
to like
employ people so well what i'd like you
to do
is sometime soon once we all get
vaccinated once i get my shot you get
your shot
bring the clacker and i want you to do
next time
i need just a little of that i just need
a little of that in my life and if
you're doing it
just you with all the cardboard cutouts
i'll be thrilled okay good
i'm happy to do it really happy to
support thank you so much
yeah i know we both know that's never
happening but thank you for saying it
would
uh hey thank you so much for talking to
me kyra i love discussing things with
you
you've always you're always a great
guest and um i'm happy for you
thank you take good care so good to see
you
good to see you now here have a giant
glass of water yeah here it comes